Fury
Why haven't you called any
of your special friends. This war
Is one
I have to fight
alone
This world is burning.
This is personal.
You're the most wanted man
on the planet
Well
Momma always said I was special.
Marvel Studios Secret Invasion
Welcome back, everyone.
it's Charlie.
This'll be my Secret Invasion.
Episode 5 Trailer Video.
There are only a couple episodes left,
so they have to wrap things up
pretty quickly.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs here,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're doing a giveaway for Disney
plus memberships.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and post all your
theories for the last two episodes.
what it seems like they'll do
is they'll just pick up
in the aftermath of that big attack
because you see all the cars,
what looks like Emilia Clark's guy,
a character cradling Taylor's body.
People wondering, is he really dead?
Is totally possible that he is dead.
but they supposedly I mean, quote unquote
supposedly killed off
Maria Hill in the first episode.
Ned Stark, Game of Thrones style
never thought that they would kill her off
just because they kept bringing her back.
in fact, one of the only big Avengers
level characters are characters
that were in the Avengers movies
that I expect them to kill off during
the series or than I originally expected
would have been Skrull, Rhodey
part of the big thing in this last
two episodes that they have to do
is they have to convince the president,
who is still alive at this point.
But it looks like Nick
very just took him to the hospital.
convince him that Rhodey really
is a Skrull or get Skrull
Rhodey to turn back into a Skrull
in his presence,
these way to do that would be to kill him
right in front of the president.
Skrulls revert to their natural state
when they're killed.
it definitely seemed like they wanted
to use episode four
to get you to hate Skrull.
Rhodey even more.
The way he was talking to Nick
Fury like you're
not supposed to talk to Nick Fury
that way.
He's definitely going to come back for you
fury ose that female Skrull
pretending to be him a couple of bullets.
it looks like Emilia Clarke meets with
Nick Fury and they decide what to do next.
Like, how do we salvage this situation?
Because what is Gravik going to do now?
It seems like he might just continue
his original plan
to continue to try and kill the president
and to make him think that the Russians
were the ones behind it
because he wants to set off World
War Three.
Originally, that was their whole plan.
Get the humans to kill themselves
through mutually assured destruction
like a much messier version of the snap.
there's also the footage of Nick
Fury meeting with Sonya Failsworth
at his gravestone, Nicholas J.
Fury. It seems like the gravestone
has been there for a while.
It would have either had been put there
after the snap in Avengers Infinity War,
when they definitely knew that he was
dead, at least for a little while
Or it could be from back when he faked his
death in Captain America Winter Soldier,
because he did make everybody at least
officially believe that he had died.
the way Nick Fury talked
about his relationship with the president
when he was meeting with Squirrel Rhodey
in previous episodes
made it sound like people
in the government
just in general,
like people in the military,
knew that he was still alive really good
example in Spider-Man, far from home,
he was walking around, even though it was
the Talos version of Nick Fury.
People saw Nick Fury
and they knew that he was alive.
you see him grab his stash of weapons
that he's keeping there.
It looks like some star charts here.
That's
probably just based on his relationship
with the other skrulls
the past several years,
Tales kept talking about all the things
that he professionally accomplished
because of the Skrulls like
you accomplished all these great deeds.
You even put the Avengers together
on the backs of what the Skrulls did.
But he also may have benefited
from the skrulls technology,
which I think is also tails
his idea to the idea that he wanted asylum
in the United States. Look, see,
they can benefit from our culture,
they can benefit from our technology.
we can make all their lives
that much better.
That also makes you wonder if there's
a similar situation with the Asgardians
because they have such advanced
technology. But.
I'm sure Valkyrie is trying to prevent
all humans from gaining access
to all their technology.
Sort of like a Wakanda situation
in Black Panther.
What kind of forever
with all the vibranium
you have a very
advanced race of people
living in a special area that have control
over a very highly valued resource
or technology.
everybody else wants it,
but they're not willing to completely
give everyone access to it
just because it would probably lead
to the demise of the entire Earth.
that idea will continue into Captain
America four Brave New World with TMNT.
They're actually finally going to address
the giant dead
celestial in the Indian Ocean.
supposedly they're going to see that
adamantium is found on team its body like
it just grows naturally on their body
you have to imagine that
the rest of the world all races each other
to try and claim it for themselves.
we get some new footage of Nick
Fury's wife joining G'iah, it seems like
they're fighting Gravik's Skrulls
not sure which mission they're on here.
It seems like fury goes one way
and they go another way.
They're just trying to deal with
both of Gravik's
groups like you have Skrull, Rhodey.
Then you also have a Gravik is doing.
Nick Fury eventually goes to Gravik's base
at the abandoned Russian power plant
that they're calling New Skrullos.
be this might be from episode six.
In the finale,
they had this big final fight
in the Super Skrull room near that device
where they give themselves powers
they're also agents handling collapsing
Ian's hand in the box.
And it looks like Gravik
doesn't have it yet,
at least at this point,
and he means to steal it.
that would give them
super strength and durability.
And if all the powers that they're giving
themselves are meant to be Easter eggs
for the super Skrull in the comics
in the Fantastic Four's Powers,
because that's the way
it played out in the comics originally.
in this equation, Cool Obsidian
would be like a version of the thing
we haven't seen them
use Frost PS Powers yet,
which we know
that they're giving themselves.
Normally you would think that
that would just be called
base powers like Frost Powers.
But if.
All these are meant to be fantastic
for Easter eggs for their powers,
it would have to represent
invisible woman's powers. And that's
either a cloaking or invisibility
forcefield, something similar to that.
but I don't think it's limited to that.
Like, the whole idea is they could just
continue grafting powers onto themselves.
They're looking for other biological
material from super powered individuals.
when it seems that they're heading
towards a situation
where either Nick Fury has to kill Gravik
with or without Emilia Clarke's
help, or him doing
something that leads to his death
like Gravik does, something
that inadvertently winds up
getting himself killed.
he seems way too overpowered
for Nick Fury.
the only way
Nick Fury winds up killing him,
I think is either by outsmarting him
or with G'iah's help
Just because she'd be as strong as he is.
can let me know how you think his story
is going to end in the finale,
like Gravik probably winds up dying.
But how does he wind up dying
Then people asking what happens to the
rest of those million Skrulls after this?
Because some of them were just happy
to live their lives peacefully,
not really caring about the whole secret
invasion, spin on everything.
end, even though Gravik turned,
the high council bent them to his will.
Originally
they didn't want to take over the earth.
They were happy to just take over world
governments
and live secretly amongst them
and wield power, So the idea is that
even though some Skrulls weren't that bad,
some of them were still very, very bad.
what it seems that they might wind up
doing
is outing the skrulls in the president's
presence.
That might wind up being was Skrull
rotting like you kill him
in the president's presence.
So he realizes that it is a threat.
Like, oh,
there are skrulls amongst us everywhere,
but because of Taylor's sacrifice.
They'll pay that off and the president
will grant some of the good skrulls
amnesty.
Maybe, but things don't end
well either way.
Things do not end well for the Skrulls
most of the government, you have to
imagine, would hate
the idea of skrulls living amongst them
no matter what the circumstances were.
And the issue probably just continues
into the next election.
If the president survives, end
they give Norman Osborn's secret invasion
storyline two Thunderbolt
Ross and Thunderbolt
Ross winds up winning the presidency,
taking credit for getting rid
of a bunch of the bad Skrulls you've to
imagine him taking the presidency
on a platform of security in the face
of what happened during secret invasion,
turning the United States at least into
something more akin to a police state.
the kind of doing the same thing
with Daredevil born again and Kingpin
becoming mayor
during that year, mayor of New York City.
to make another defenders pun ruling New
York City with an iron fist vulnerable.
Ross is doing that just on a larger scale
a lot of people also asking, is Cobie
Smulders really dead?
Well, she winds up coming back Normally,
I would say they're definitely
faking her death.
But the way they showed you her death
in the first episode, like they lingered
on her body for so long, they really,
really want you to think that she's dead.
We'll see about that.
I wouldn't
be surprised that there is a big twist
in the end when she shows up again.
but as for other agents of shield
characters coming back, like,
I don't think Chloe Bennet
is coming back at this point.
I do think they'll bring Quake
back into the MCU at some point.
It just doesn't seem like it's
going to be a secret invasion.
The way things are going right now.
Anson Mount also said
that he's been talking to Marvel
about coming back
as another version of Black Bolt again,
meaning
that Marvel does have plans to do more
Inhumans related stuff
alongside their mutants in X-Men stuff
in the future, Even though X-Men stuff
is going to take center stage pretty soon,
most of the storylines, though,
the Secret Invasion is helping to set up
with what's happening in the finale
is what's going on during Captain America
four Brave New World.
maybe a little bit of the Thunderbolts
movie too.
But the whole idea is
that the Thunderbolts
is sort of taking the place of Norman
Osborn's dark Avengers.
They're kind of doing the same vibe
with those version of the Thunderbolts.
But that's meant to be more of a Val
movie.
Like Val puts the Thunderbolts together
as she has been doing
since Falcon and Winter Soldier.
When she was talking to U.S.
Agent, she was talking about putting
the Thunderbolts together, basically,
I've already done a couple of videos
about the Thunderbolts movie
because that'll be happening
right through Captain America 4.
They'll be introducing
the sentry character during that,
so I'll put links for that down
the description below right after this.
The next big Marvel thing that's happening
will be a Loki season 2.
That'll be like the whole Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty side of things.
Like they'll be doing a lot with that
storyline during the Loki series,
even though there is going to be
an actor strike
and there's a bunch of crazy stuff
happening right now,
the Loki episodes will still come in
October no matter what.
And then we also have
Asoka episodes that are coming in August,
but that's Star Wars stuff.
So talk more about that.
during my Star Wars videos
there, couple the really big things that
just released from both Marvel and DC.
So I'll try to do videos for everything
as quickly as possible.
Everyone click here for that new Deadpool
three teaser video of Wolverine
and click here for all my Secret Invasion
Episode Videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!